i'm so excited to see you thank you for
coming on the show
okay so here's the thing my mom says to
me
hi mom hi mom so so random last night
she gets angry when i'm doing press and
i don't tell her i said i'm doing you
and she says
you're you're doing her and i go yeah
and so she says i watch she knew what
time you came on in philadelphia
and i was like how random mom that's
such a random a white girl
what a random freak she's so it's like
so and so she loves you
so mom i'm on her show hi say hi to
clara
clara clara say hi hi clara how are you
i'm so glad that you watched the show
that means
everything let me tell you you don't
understand this is going to make
her life i'm so glad she's watching and
she's in pennsylvania or philly is that
what you said philadelphia yeah
i'm so thrilled and i'm so excited to be
talking
to your son you know when i look at your
body of work and the
careers you know i mean think about it
the academy awards
you produce monsters ball that's halle
berry
precious you know got gaby city bay a
nomination
monique who was in precious won the gold
and now you know andrew day is nominated
for billy holliday and i even read
stories like taraji p henson wanted to
work with you
you kept that in your mind and then you
brought it back around
when you were launching empire and the
amount of careers
that you have supported is extraordinary
thanks drew yeah it's crazy you know
you're just trying to
tell a story and in in telling the story
you're trying to
uh you're trying to keep uh people of
color
and women and lgbtq people employed
um and that's just so subconscious of me
and in that you just sort of
you you bring your life to and your life
experience and what you want
to uh the screen in front of the screen
and back of the screen so
thank you for acknowledging that billy
holliday
is someone that we all know and loved
and andra day
came on the show we had a very profound
conversation
she won the golden globe a few days
later um congratulations on that
and her academy award nomination was
soon announced thereafter and
my daughter was actually born to god
bless the child by billie holiday
yes it was quite the auspicious moment
by the way
and i have listened to billie holiday my
entire life i listen to her all weekend
long
everything i've ever done it she is the
soundtrack of my life
and what i asked andra is now having
seen your film
how i should listen to her now
knowing the information that you brought
to light
you know you loved the ladies things the
blues film with diana ross
why was this something that having loved
her
loved her story had to see it through
and tell a different narrative about
billie holiday
i loved lady sings the blues you know
yeah it really
changed my life drew it beca i was 13
and i was um in philadelphia and it was
the first time i'd seen two people that
looked like me kissing late uh
uh billy d williams and diana ross and
she was so stunning and richard pryor
was so funny and the fashions were so
fabulous and the music was so
incredible and i could smell the fried
chicken popping off the screen i felt
like i was in my home
and i walked out of theater thinking i
want to make people feel like that
and uh and i think that was the reason i
know that that was a reason that got me
into
um and also the idea of drugs
even though i had not experienced drugs
at that time
this is the first time i'm talking about
this even then i realized that uh
i was gonna have my dance with that with
that beast
but that was many years later and um but
anyway many years later i i read the
script
that susan laurie parks wrote brilliant
playwright
uh and i understood that that wasn't the
story though it was a
it was a romanticized version of what um
billie holiday's life was and then i
listened to strange fruit
and i i listened to it with different
ears
it affected me it was ugly it was i i
cried i understood it and
um i said i have to tell this woman's
story this woman's story has been buried
the government has succeeded in
brainwashing me my parents
my family everyone that she was just a
drug addict
and i associated
my father and and and and the
relationship the
very bad relationship that i have with
my dad
with her relationship with her mama and
uh you know when i work it's therapeutic
it's healing for me so though i wanted
to explore
the civil rights of it all i also was
trying to find me
and um and i found me and billie holiday
i you know i was able to do the film
sober which was a
verse for me i so relate
to what you are saying as far as my
personal experience was that
somehow films and filmmaking and the
families and the community i built
through them
kept me straight no matter what i was
going through in
my personal life or with things i did
think sometimes
there was artistry in my hedonism
and i suppose that so many people feel
that way that they cannot give it up
that as accountable as work will make
you and as much as that's your therapy
and your way into the world
you still have a personal struggle on
the side and
why do you think that you myself artists
struggle with addiction in that way or
hedonism or fueling that creative fire
as if if that gets extinguished we are
dark and everything is lost
all you know what's interesting why
here's the thing
it is it is it is we have um
people are cool and i don't think that
they understand that this
really is a it's a disease
and um for artists we have an escape
you know i feel blessed that i haven't
escaped you know when
i was put in a trash can at a young age
for um
walking down the stairs in my mother's
high heels
i escaped and i pretended that i was uh
aladdin on a magic carpet and
and that's how i've dealt with all of my
pain
uh i dealt with all of my pain over the
years escape
through drugs uh not wanting to feel
yeah and um it's just about learning how
to feel right now
how to feel and how to be present and uh
and how to share my story with other
people so that i can so that
i can help other people you have uh
ghetto film school
which i can't think of a better person
to shepherd
everybody because you are the example
of what is possible in storytelling
filmmaking producing directing